what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today i am going to be reacting to
redhead girl tried to pull a misogyny
card on us before i start do not forget
to subscribe to the channel
guys guys i'm trying to get 20 000
subscribers this month
it's a big goal i need your help hit
that subscribe button
ring the notification bell that way
you're going to be notified of my daily
videos you guys don't want to miss any
you don't all right i'm not going to lie
to you though
i'm gonna drink my smoothie while i do
this
if you guys don't like it i'm sorry i
just don't care
[Music]
okay
liz you gotta either adapt with it or
complain but that's how you oh that's
all you really can do yeah
yeah men complain when they're young and
can't get girls women complain when
they're older and can't get a husband
yeah okay i think just going back to the
question though i think
it's a little unfortunate that you guys
don't want to at least even just say
that you think that it's wrong the
reality is wrong because look that the
fact that that's the reality
that's the reality of course yeah i see
that but
the fact that you guys just can't answer
my question and say yes men are
wrong it's a little it's a little
telling and you know what you guys are
saying the whole time that we don't want
to answer questions but you guys didn't
even answer my questions so
we did it we just did no time
multiple times you guys said i can't
comment on that no comment but that's
fine if you know
we just give you a literally long-ass
answer
of why reality is the way it is but if
you would have asked us
okay but what do you think what do you
think was okay but don't worry about
what other people are
outside of it but how do you this is the
difference between how men and women
think this is a perfect example right
now guys take your [ __ ] notebooks
down
notice how we said we accept reality
right for what it is
[ __ ] our feelings we accept it for what
it is yeah
you guys want us to get on the female
lens and feel it's wrong or right our
hope and we're telling you that reality
is immoral so we don't care
men aren't our feelings are irrelevant
i don't have a problem with this it's
like it is what it is so far so good
except objective reality so oh how do i
feel about this we don't feel anything
we accept it i understand the reality
but this was the segment this was the
part of the show that you guys were
saying do you have any questions for us
and i was asking you
for your opinion and you guys were
saying oh i can't comment on this
maybe you guys should just watch this
podcast back and see what i was saying
because i feel like you guys are not
understanding or you just wanna
you don't wanna say the words which i
understand because this is what your
podcast
like relies on is your whole basis of
your podcast you guys are like reframing
misogynistic ideals
for modern men to consume and be okay
so but whenever i hear girls say that
i usually think they're full of [ __ ] to
be honest
we'll see we'll see what she has to say
that's that was my question and if you
guys didn't want to answer it
what was misogynist yeah can you tell us
what was misogynistic about the podcast
please tell us you guys can just scroll
through your instagram page you guys
can you tell us what was misogynistic
just one thing one thing because that's
pretty serious claim
it is that's a pretty that's a pretty uh
you guys have your preferences and you
guys have your how your preference
your preferences which is fine but there
are definitely some misogynistic
tendencies you guys have especially
throughout your instagram page
yeah for example on one of your posts um
i believe you said
there was an example that you wanted to
hook up with a girl she didn't want to
hook up with you
um which is fine like you said like you
said it was fine yeah um
but i had to put her in her place so i
had to
i said okay guys if a girl doesn't want
to hook up with you that's fine
but put her in her place you got to call
another girl in front of her and let her
know
it just seems like i don't like that
that is so disrespectful
that's so disrespectful in that in that
sec
in that little video i saw it's like
your ego is so hurt by the fact i don't
think it's misogynistic
i think it's just disrespectful that a
woman doesn't want to sleep with you
that you have to
go out of your way to disrespect her and
disrespect her instead of just leaving
her apartment and going
you have the freedom to do what you want
to do you want to go sleep with five
girls after her that's fine
but it's just like you know you guys
definitely have those misogynistic
tendencies
it's not misogynistic it's just rude
that's so rude if a girl doesn't want to
sleep with you
i see it in your comments girls you know
going off in your comments and it's just
like but i get it this is the basis of
your podcast this is
why guys watch your podcast your fan
base is
just like you guys you know a lot of the
time i'm sure um
but i mean it's interesting to hear and
i thank you for inviting me
and all right no no no no no i gotta i
gotta rebut that real quick no of course
yeah so
okay so when a woman says i don't want
to have sex is she
is she's making she's making a boundary
essentially right she's saying she's
she doesn't want to have sex right so
what is wrong with me
also having a boundary and saying if you
don't want to have sex now you no longer
get my attention
leave what is wrong with that no there's
something wrong with that okay so how's
that misogynistic that i'm exerting a
boundary as well
in response to her exerting her boundary
no saying to leave is fine
i'm saying um you said that you're like
no guys
if she you gotta put her in her place
you gotta put her in your place and in
that moment
you gotta call girl yeah i don't think
that's misogynistic i think it's rude
and condescending
that's like a girl saying if you don't
take me to a five-star restaurant
i'ma leave i'm not gonna talk to you and
i know some girls are like that but i
would say the same thing like those
girls are disrespectful and rude
and not there for the right reasons and
if a guy
doesn't see any value in getting to know
you before he sleeps with you
he's probably just trying to use you for
sex so you know i wouldn't even be mad
if that happened to me i would just
think that i dodged a bullet clearly
girl in front of her i'm pretty sure
yeah i said no i said i'll call a girl
in front of her yeah but the point is is
that
you need to remember keep in mind that
i'm teaching this is people that like
drama
and this is why you could tell he likes
drama um nothing against him personally
but
if you're someone that doesn't like
drama you know what you do
you kick her out of your apartment fine
block her don't ever you
don't ever have to talk to her again but
he clearly likes the drama so he's going
to like put on this
scene in front of her i'm going to call
another girl
in front of you like again do i think
that's misogynistic no
do i think it's rude disrespectful yeah
men not women so what a lot of guys will
do
is they'll let their girls sit there and
continue to get their non-sexual
attention and think it's okay and hope
and i'm not telling men to simp either
i'm not telling men to sim so i don't
know when this
is happening but on a first date a girl
is not comfortable sleeping with you
when she's never met you before
like i don't think that's a huge deal
reinforced you're reinforcing
undesirable behavior from the woman
and you're letting her know it's
acceptable for you to with to withhold
sex from me
and what i'm telling men is no that's
not but it could just be that she's not
comfortable having sex with you yet
like i don't think women are really
built for casual relationships and
casual sex so i would never tell a girl
to sleep with a guy
as soon as possible and it has nothing
to do with like the leverage
or anything that they talk about on the
channel
it's just take your time get to know
that person
see his true colors and then if you're
comfortable go ahead
but there's value in getting to know
someone before you sleep with them
not acceptable kick her out of your
house just like you have the ability
to exert your boundaries i don't want to
have sex i don't feel comfortable
cool that's fine on the male side i
don't feel comfortable hanging out with
you anymore now
you have to leave the problem is this
ladies anytime a man exerts a boundary
right of what he wants from a woman
especially if it's sexual
it's considered misogynistic so in other
words
not misogynistic just rude to be honest
just rude that's cool if you want to do
that that's totally fine
and that's why like i tell girls i would
tell girl i don't have any girls that
follow me really but if i did
i would tell girls to take your time
getting to know someone before you sleep
with them
because you're going to wind up with
players like that
that don't see you as anything but sex
so yeah two words it's okay for women to
say what they want from men but it is
not okay for men to say what they want
from women
and what we simply tell guys is you have
the option to kick her out too you don't
have to sit there and tolerate her
leveraging sex against you for
compliance that is not misogynistic can
do you know what the definition of
misogyny is
i'm saying that's not you telling her to
leave or you
leaving is what does what does misogyny
say she's using the wrong
word like she misogynistic isn't the
right word it's rude disrespectful
unkind so this is misogyny
misogyny it's like um you know being
against women in general no it is the
hatred and or contempt of women
yes where do we say we hate women
definition please tell us where we're
where do we hate women where where do
you hate women
yes is that the only definition of
misunderstanding yeah yeah
which is why which is a very strong word
it's a very yeah that's a very serious
accusation so if you're going to say
that then back it up with we have no
problem yeah i mean i just
i just gave you a whole example you can
play it back on the podcast later if you
want to listen to it again but and
you you've even even called a woman a
[ __ ] on your podcast live sorry for
saying the b word
how does me exerting a boundary uh show
that i hate women
maybe she meant patriarchal not no no
let her answer it let her answer it
thank you
i already explained it wasn't the fact
that you were setting a boundary you
were saying
in the video oh i have to put a woman in
her place because she doesn't want to
have sex with me
so i'm going to go ahead and call a
woman in front of her it's not misogyny
it's just
only seeing women as good for sex
in a relationship and i'm not
and by no means am i saying oh you have
to wait all this time or
um or you know
wait till you're married or whatever i'm
just saying there's value in getting to
know someone before you sleep with them
just to make a point and feel and make
her feel disrespected yeah yeah so he's
going out of his way
to create drama basically you're gonna
go through the drama
of disrespecting a girl instead of just
kicking her out
but i don't know some people just like
the drama
it's just like that that type of
behavior is just so unnecessary if you
if if you're
that if your ego is that hurt that a
woman doesn't want to see it's funny i
kind of agree with her but i don't think
it's misogyny
asleep with you then just leave or just
tell her like why do you have to be
disrespectful like that
and then like on another video you were
on live calling a woman a [ __ ] it's
like i just think that's a little
disrespectful very disrespectful okay so
there's a couple things that here so
number one
uh by telling a girl to leave that does
not mean that i hate to hate women
i didn't say that that's what
misogynistic means means you hate women
that's what you're saying basically
i didn't say because he told her to
leave this misogynistic i'm saying he
was saying that he
guys you gotta put women in their place
like if we're some submissive dogs that
need to be put in our place like no we
don't
who leaves relationships men or women
who leads relationships yeah um men most
of the time yeah okay
so by asserting dominance what are you
doing you're taking leadership of the
relationship right or the interaction
correct
yeah okay so you're asserting dominance
which is which is what men should do
and what makes men attractive in the
first place so
attraction isn't moral as i said before
and nowhere in there did i say i hate
women by
exerting a boundary like i said there's
nothing wrong with a woman saying i
don't want to have sex and it's also
nothing wrong for me to say you need to
leave and i'm going to call another
woman
i'm in my own home i can do what i want
if i want to call a woman in front of
her that's whatever
but that in no means means i'm a
misogynist
that's true i'm saying the way i agree
with what he said
it just means you're rude and a player
and disrespectful today you talk about
women
yeah and you're it's just i'm saying the
way that what
the way you were saying it oh if a woman
doesn't want to have sex with you men
you have to put her in her place
so i don't think most men i'm just being
honest i don't think most men
have the options to be readily doing
that
you're going off of feelings like so
it's not what he said it's how he said
it right no it is what he said
yeah it's it's
it's yeah it's literally what he said
said what he said in the video you guys
can play it or rewind i don't usually
agree with the girls on this
this channel watch it i don't know what
you want to do
and like i said you've called women a
[ __ ]
it's on your instagram page i saw it
okay so hold on
i don't care if like she might have been
[ __ ] so
i don't care about that hold up hold on
yeah because that's the thing
i've called men [ __ ] i've called
women [ __ ] i've called i've insulted
everyone
here's the thing that you don't like
women have fought for equality
therefore they're equal and they can
make their own decisions correct from
from a society standpoint right same
right same privileges whatever i can
actually i can't think of a right or a
privilege that a woman has that a man
doesn't i can find privileges that women
have that men a lot
so with that said women are free to make
their choices
the difference is is that there's
consequences to these choices you don't
want to have sex
cool now you must leave nothing
misogynistic about me exerting a
boundary just like she did
number two calling a woman a [ __ ]
under what context because if a woman is
acting rude or crass
she can be called a [ __ ] just like any
other woman and or any other man
i insult everyone the same i've kicked
men off this show i've kicked women off
this show
so calling a woman women don't get
privileged for being women
just to act ridiculous and not be called
out on it
if i call a woman a [ __ ] under what
context was it she probably did
something
wrong for me to call her that are you a
misogynist because you refer to other
women as [ __ ] i'm sure you have
referred to other women as [ __ ] are
you massages for that
women when women when women refer to
other women as [ __ ] it's like oh hey
[ __ ] it's not like
you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] like no sorry
okay have you never called a woman a
[ __ ] in a degrading form
to to [ __ ] on her are you [ __ ] [ __ ]
you've never done that
of course i've called a woman are you a
misogynist
no but i'm saying i'm saying i'm trying
to say that
in that video what you were doing is
like you
it seems like your ego was so hurt that
that the girl didn't want to sleep with
you that you have to go out of your way
to call a woman
i wouldn't even say his ego was hurt it
just seemed like he wanted nothing other
than sex
from her which is fine if that's what
you want to do
i just personally would try to avoid
guys like that
in front of her just to make her feel
bad and like you're you're talk you were
talking about women in a way that you
have to teach them a lesson if they
don't want to sleep with you
and it's just like why why can't a woman
just not want to sleep with you because
she doesn't want to sleep with you and
that's okay but
you don't have to take it into that why
should there be consequences if i don't
okay hold on hold on
if if i don't if you don't want to sleep
with me why should i continue to give
you attention
you're not entitled to my time remember
can't you say yet i don't want to sleep
with you yet i'd still like to get to
know you better
i'm cute i'm curious i don't know the
exact situation
but my attention that's the problem so
women
you women are not entitled i'm going to
say that again women are
not entitled to a man's time attention
and resources
if she does not want to reciprocate on
or on her end and give him sexual access
you are not entitled to it and for a man
to exert boundaries and say listen you
got to get out
and or call another woman in front of
her it doesn't matter
you no longer want to give what the man
wants
he's within his right to kick you out
any way he sees fit just like you are
within your right to withhold sex from
him
like you just said you just said there
should be consequences
if a woman doesn't want to sleep with
you that yes it's
so troubling like that is just
you don't see how that's weird like
that's just weird
so it's okay for you to have multiple
dates consequences
it's looking for you to go on multiple
days for the guy right
for everything and you never sleep with
him that's okay too right
way i'm sorry is he entitled and
in all honesty this is why
as a girl like
i'm personally okay with a guy spending
no money when you're just getting to
know
somebody because in the beginning you're
just trying to see who they are
and get to know them you don't have to
spend a lot of money on someone you
don't know and you shouldn't spend a lot
of money on someone
just because you want to have sex with
them
that's not wise either you should try to
get to know them too but i guess it
depends on your
end goal because i probably wouldn't
teach pick up
on this channel so to having sex with me
just because he takes me on dates no
i'm saying if you go multiple days for
the guy right and you feel like you know
what
i don't want to give give him sex that's
okay right i think you should do
whatever you want to do on guys and
like sexually if you don't want to have
sex with a man after five days you don't
have to
perfect so if he wants to call a girl in
front of you that's his prerogative
right
of course i'm just saying the he was
saying to do that as a consequence
because
that is that's the that's a shame yeah
to shame a woman
because oh because you're not having sex
with me i'm going to call someone and
make you feel some type of way yes
because the consequence is him calling a
girl you know what i'm saying so i was
like
the same thing as a girl you know
punching a guy from that sex punching a
guy
no punishing punishment oh punishing a
guy the point is is that it's
but sometimes it's not even about
punishing them
it's about not being comfortable okay
not knowing them well enough
for women to withhold sex from men with
zero consequence but it's not okay to
kick out girls and or hold them to some
kind of consequence when they don't want
to give sex
you can do whatever you want i just
think that in the video that i'm talking
about
you guys are saying in a very
disrespectful way saying that there
should and
you just said there should be
consequences if she doesn't want to
sleep with you
it's like i can't say i'm sorry guys are
not entitled to your body like
regardless
and you're not entitled to a man's time
yeah and
that's true and if you want to stop
seeing a girl because she doesn't sleep
with you that's totally fine
but for me it's it's the drama like why
are you trying to create drama
sorry go ahead no go ahead i've been
talking rapey i get what you're saying
but he probably didn't mean it
in that way you know but
no no no see this is and this is the
thing
man this is and this is why this podcast
is so important
guys this is this is the reality of the
world
women want to be able to exercise the
discretion to give you sex anytime they
see fit
but they don't want you to exercise the
discretion to withdraw attention and or
time
any time you see fit when you no longer
get what you want that's not what i'm
saying
no i i literally said she doesn't want
to give me sex she's got to leave
but you guys have a problem with that
when i say there's consequences just
like i don't really care
like i'm not trying to date him so i
literally do not care
what he does in his personal time but if
if i was in that situation
that's like that would just be a turn
off
like i'd be like cool i see your true
colors like
like it just no i'm saying the manner in
which you're going about it and saying
that
women have to be like i said like have
to be punished like there's consequences
because you don't want to have sex with
me that i have to make you feel bad
i don't want to give you desired
behavior you should punish that bad
behavior and you're talking about women
as if we're like these dogs that have to
be submissive
and like trained into being these
submissive um creatures that
you know it's like there's something
wrong with that well
just so you know right most western
women are not feminine at all
so to be a part of a man's lifestyle hey
she may need to be trained to be
feminine it's like that's that's normal
so women in colombia yeah we should play
the video oh we should play the video
let's start the video and play it we got
11 000 live viewers because here's the
thing if you're going to call someone a
misogynist then you never need to be
able to back it up so we will give you
the access to the video which video was
it let's go on our instagram tate talk
and pull it up was it thank you the
thing is
post my instagram okay i think so so
sorry guys
i'm saying yeah so go on
yeah i guess it's on ig somewhere uh
we're gonna go on the fresher fit one
and here here's the thing like i said
this isn't to attack you or anything but
it's just like
if you're gonna make a claim and say
someone's a misogynist which is a pretty
uh look okay yeah that's pretty serious
how you feel by the same misogynistic
man that's a whole
another you guys may think that like
obviously it sounds like i'm being very
harsh right now but
i'm not saying you guys are flat out
gonna be saying misogynistic
things like oh women ain't you know
s-h-i-t whatever but i'm saying i can
tell that you guys have a lot of
misogynistic tendencies in the way you
think maybe and like
oh really i feel like you guys should be
a little i don't know just be a little
she's backtracking now
open-minded to that i think i mean
there's nothing wrong with like
being open-minded to your flaws
sometimes i think everyone should
so so so you're saying that we hate
women basically i didn't when did i say
that massage
is the hate of one yeah i understand
that you're taking this extreme i said
that you guys
just like a lot of men have some
misogynistic tendencies and i think
people like people
should you should be open to like maybe
understanding some of your flaws just
like
you know i should be open to
understanding my flaws i don't think
there's anything wrong with that we can
all improve in a lot of ways
but we're asking you you're saying we're
massaging you know chris
okay so all right let's uh let's which
video is it which one
no it's more some more i think it's a
tick tock which one is it
from now uh it was on instagram i forgot
what it was called
down down you got me when the older ones
come down down
sam so you scroll all the way down to uh
find the video
i don't remember exactly where it was
okay come down
come down i'm still trying to figure
i think this one here was it this one
yeah no no no i don't want to have
bedroom five yeah
is that that one i'm not sure that one
yeah is this one here play
all right there we go this is it
is it right when the girl's at your crib
and she says oh i don't want to have any
bedroom fun
totally cool you can't get mad you
basically get up
say all right no problem and you're
gonna go call another girl
okay and then what's gonna happen is
she's gonna hear you talking to another
girl
competition anxiety spikes and then
you're going to come back and you're
going to tell listen
i respect your boundaries i understand
you don't want to have any
bedroom fun but i got my needs and
i'll see you later and you tell her to
leave simple as that guys
never ever let a girl
leverage bedroom fun against you to try
to get some compliance
she's within her right to not give you
the fun but you're within your right to
get the fund from somebody else
don't be stupid don't chase replace okay
okay let's just be honest most guys
do not have the options to just replace
i'm i'm just being honest
just being honest 80 of men aren't
having sex so
second thing yeah i really don't care if
he does that
i just that's so disrespectful oh my god
what part about that was misogynistic
please tell me because that
to me makes common sense if i don't if
you don't have sex with me cool
you say you're right you can leave if
you want to but guess what i got my
rights as well
i want to get laid hey susie what's up
come through
what's my life so what is misogynistic
about that you have your right to
whatever you want to do after that but
i'm saying uh
you don't see the part in the video
where he's like you literally you said
you have to manipulate the woman just
because
she played these mind games because she
didn't want to have sex with that
yeah like give her anxiety like
literally give a woman anxiety because
she doesn't
yeah because she doesn't want to have
sex with you you said it there's no
manipulation in the video
you just said it yeah she can leave at
any time
what do you say respect her boundaries
she can leave one more time
did you
so you want to give a woman anxiety
because she doesn't want to have sex
with you
okay obviously you don't understand how
women work you said in the video i mean
but i got the point of the video tour
you know like if that's what you're
looking
for just to hook up the other person has
to respect that exactly i know
and if you tell me well clearly they
don't respect it because you guys are
saying
we're misogynist for exerting that
boundary you should be tactful like when
you talk to people like you have to be
see for me it's just going out of your
way to create drama
uh you know you could do the same thing
and not
and not go out of your way to like be
dramatic and
be disrespectful but
you know i could see why like the
replace
thing if you're just looking for casual
sex you don't have to but
it's it's the right thing to do to
consider their feelings
you could be like hey she clearly
doesn't consider my feelings you call
her in front of the girl here's the
thing
like hey can you why i gotta do
something why should i respect her
feelings
when she's not giving me what i want
she's not respecting my feelings
so why should see that's the problem
women want it one-sided i want you to
treat me like a princess regardless of
whatever i want you to
give me the attention whatever but when
a man puts his foot down and says listen
i have boundaries too and i have
requirements as well you don't want to
[ __ ] it out
that's one and i was very polite about
it too but if i call another girl
right here's the thing i can't choose
how a woman feels
it's fine
i don't think it's polite to say i i
have my needs get out
oh my goodness i call another girl it's
called competition anxiety which means
other girls want guys that other women
want to be with
so no that's just that's a real thing
that's a real thing
another girl and she feels competition
anxiety it's not my fault that she feels
that way
i'm doing what i'm gonna do how she
feels is irrelevant to me right it's
fine that she does
that you do tell her you know hey um i'm
looking for like a hookup or whatever
so like you know it's fine like i can
have somebody over but to actually
call somebody in front like that's kind
of like it's crap like a little
disrespectful
lame it's disrespectful hold on hold on
no no it's disrespectful that she
doesn't want to have sex
it's disrespectful that a woman doesn't
want to
okay it's disrespectful because i've
spent my time hanging out with this
woman
and she doesn't want to have sex so
therefore she doesn't want to have sex
cool you got to leave now like i said it
is
that's the problem uh like it is okay
for women to i mean he's just giving me
the exact reason
why i would tell girls to wait i'm
having sex because you will get rid of
the guys that just want you
for sex exercise they're um they're
they're able to leverage sex against men
for compliance but it's not okay for men
to leverage attention for compliance
well that if that's been established at
that point that's you know it is what it
is yeah but it's applied though because
if
if you're going on a date with a guy and
then you're like you know what i'm going
out there with a guy
spend hours with him have him spend the
money
then you go to his place and you're like
you know what i don't want to have sex
that's mad disrespectful why don't you
tell them in the first place you know
what i don't like it that much
but let's if you're the woman say hey
you know what i don't like it that much
but let's be friends
and see what happens no sex tonight tell
them up front don't wait don't play this
kind of monster perspective and i have a
different type of view
so sure in my opinion i feel like that's
not bad
why don't you tell them to just be
friends for yeah i could see that
you want to deal with the guy and you
don't like the guy and let's say that
you said you've been dating for a long
time if he invites you to his house
don't go to his house
some girls go to a guy's house and like
they're in bed with the guy
and they're cuddling with the guy and
they're there making out with you
doing it the most and then when the guy
tries to make a move
they're like whoa i'm out of here like
no don't end up in his room in his bed
if you don't want to do anything
there you go from the beginning if
you're at dinner and you i think a lot
of times girls just want to like spend
time
with that guy um
yeah but yeah she's right you shouldn't
be in that situation you have no
intentions of being with that guy do not
go home with them i gotta work in the
morning
i gotta go home early you don't have to
do that
cuddling in the whole thing that's
that's not it's not gonna work
the point i'm trying to make which you
guys just don't understand is a man's
attention is not free just like your sex
isn't free
he is not entitled to spend another
second with you if you don't want to
[ __ ]
and that's the problem that women have
here you went to the extent of calling
me a misogynist
for exerting a boundary which the woman
also exerted as well
it was in response to her asserting her
right i don't want to have sex
cool you no longer going to get my
attention
how is that misogynistic than me hating
women i think that's me being
intelligent about my time i've repeated
myself like five times but i'll say it
again
um the definition of misogyny hate and
or contempt
for women i think you guys are not
straight up misogynist because that
would be stupid to be a straight up
blatant
i don't think you're blatant about it
but you have a lot of misogynistic
tendencies
which i think that's the key to this
podcast that you guys are able to
reframe these ideas
into a way that's consumable for like
modern men to be like oh yeah this is
okay to listen to which
that's a whole other thing but i was
just saying that i mean the manipulation
part and like
the entitlement that you felt in that
video just because a woman
doesn't want to have sex with you aka
the audacity you have to punish her you
have to play these manipulatives so why
are you entitled to his time then
i'm not entitled to anyone's time you're
saying by me removing her from the place
then she's not telling me
i did not say that are you to what i'm
saying no because you said you said
it's misogynistic saying those
manipulative games like why
the the what you said in the video that
you feel entitled to having sex to
to um sorry that that you
feel like there should be consequences
to the fact that she doesn't want to
have sex with you yes
there are consequences what's wrong with
that she no longer gets my attention
that's the consequence if i if i'm out
with a girl right and
obviously i know what i want she knows
what i want why
even come to my room like i'm just
saying look yeah if you don't if you're
not into the guy you're not into that
understand it's your choice you can walk
away say you know what this is fun
i gotta go home it was nice meeting you
yeah it's done right there is done
but record a spot and then be like all
right i don't know
you know what is that like just just
don't show up sometimes people don't
like to
give everything the first time they meet
someone because that's that can be a
little overwhelming and that's fine
so maybe they might want to sleep with
you the few days later maybe
here's a problem we're talking about
what the woman wants what about what the
man wants
why is it when a man exerts what he
wants it's misogynistic
that's the problem i mean again it's not
misogynistic
but this is what i always say on the
channel you reap what you sow
so with that mindset do you think he's
gonna marry a girl that's not
promiscuous how does he expect that to
work
and they always talk about how they
don't want promiscuous women but again
you reap what you sell
it's not misogynistic you're both no no
no no okay i'm getting kind of tired
um yeah um i wasn't offended by that at
all
um i don't care what he does
in his free time i don't think he's a
misogynist i think he's a player
players are allowed to play so let me
know in the comments if you guys agree
or disagree do not forget to subscribe
to the channel and bring that
notification
bell um while you're at it follow my
instagram
um it's just pearly things but with a z
um
i'm trying to get 10 000 followers on
there so if you guys can follow me on
there i would really appreciate it i
will talk to you guys
next time